meine kollegin arizona sehen wir sie
schon ist für uns vor ort und lebt seit
25 jahren auf mallorca wie es die
situation gerade ich stehe gerade an der
promenade in cala ratjada und sie ist
immer noch nicht so belebt es fehlen
einfach die touristen seit dem 11 mai
darf man ja schon die restaurants und
hotels eröffnen allerdings fehlen halt
die touristen hat so die einzige belebte
stadt ist gerade weil da die restaurants
und und david maiwald auch mit der
einheimischen kundschaft rechnen und der
ballermann ist ja sonst auch ein
ausflugsort der deutschen wie sieht es
am ballermann aus hast du glaub ich auch
für uns unterwegs
genau da ist für mich immer noch
trostlos und leer die betreiber und die
restaurants stehen eigentlich schon in
den startlöchern es müssen nur noch die
urlauber kommen
gibt es denn schon konkrete pläne
ab wann die deutschen wieder in auf
spanier also auf mallorca wieder urlaub
machen können
also im moment befinden wir uns ja noch
bis zum 24 mai im alarmzustand der soll
wieder ein monat verlängert werden bis
zum 24
juni jetzt war aber allerdings im
gespräch
am 24 juli in der vierten phase den
flughafen wieder zu eröffnen also für
den tourismus damit sowie der urlaub auf
die insel aber vor juli technisch nicht
mit einem saisonstart auf mallorca